a lack of government oversight creates
problems in tracking the growing number
of potentially dangerous reactions to
cosmetics a new study says reports of
adverse reactions to cosmetic cosmetics
rather and personal care products more
than doubled to nearly 1,600 complaints
between 2015 and 2016 that's estimated
to be just a fraction of the actual
number our doctor Tara Narula joins us
at the table to discuss
good to see you Tara you so what kind of
products are we talking about what
reactions are you worried about these
are products that we probably all use at
some point this morning deodorant
moisturizers makeup hair care products
perfumes a very common we use them every
day for years and certain brands or any
kind of do it could be potentially any
brand it's basically this industry of
cleansing beautification and changing
our appearance that's the industry we're
talking about and so the concern raised
by this letter was basically that there
are about 396 adverse events reported
every year and that probably is the tip
of the iceberg because we know that
research has shown that usually less
than 10% of adverse events are really
reported and in this industry there is
really very minimal safety oversight I
think that's surprising to a lot of
people to learn in 2015 to 2016 this
jump that you talked about was primarily
from three different product lines hair
care skin care and tattoos and the the
complaints can range from skin
irritation rashes hair loss allergic
reactions and then longer-term concerns
about cancer reproductive problems and
endocrine disruptions is it push for
more oversight I think there needs to be
on some level more information and more
oversight the problem now to really to
understand charlie is that there's no
need for pre market safety approval
manufacturers don't need to report to
the FDA if there are complaints there is
no need to register products there's no
need to give the FDA ingredients so what
has happened is that we've created a
situation of passive surveillance where
products get put on the market and then
we wait for complaints to arise and then
the FDA can investigate and even in that
situation they really don't recall
products from the market well you would
hope that most people would use
deodorant hair care so is there
something that we should be looking at
when we go to buy these products it
would
be nice if there really was but it's
very hard for consumers to navigate this
because there are thousands of chemicals
that make up all kinds of ingredients
the manufacturers don't have to list the
ingredients because they can be called
trade secrets or special formulations
the chemical are we supposed to dude
here so see the dermatologist we spoke
to who was one of the authors of this
letter basically suggested keeping it
simple so pick products that have the
fewest ingredients so at least likely to
cause reactions pick products that have
chemicals that have been around kind of
tried true and tested over years not
necessarily the newest its most exciting
chemical or ingredient you also want to
pick products that are die free
preservative free fragrance free and
clearly if you have an issue I think the
big reason for this letter was to say
report it report it to the FDA report it
to the manufacturer the FDA has a
website you can go to the Center for
Food Safety and applied nutrition where
you can fill out an online form and the
more data we have as the the author said
if we can't measure it we can't manage
it that's what we need to do get measure
can manage exactly Thank You Darren
thank you very much sir